à genoux pour prier
debout pour chanter
une centaine de manifestants se sont
réunis vendredi devant l'un des lieux de
culte des plus emblématiques de la
capitale avec une seule invocation un
certain nombre de personnes ont
considéré qu'il fallait dire aux
pouvoirs publics notre détermination à
récupérer notre droit et notre liberté
essentielle a assisté au culte
catholique en l'espèce le dimanche est
d'ailleurs les autres jours de la
semaine aussi est notre droit d'assister
à la messe tout simplement
et voilà que dans ce rayon d'un
kilomètre de circulation dans lequel on
peut sortir tous les jours
il ne nous est pas permis de passer une
heure par semaine à la messe la laisse a
beau faire 1000 m elle a l'humilité de
se retirer devant dieu la france alors
du confinement jusqu'au 1er décembre -
l'organisation de célébrations dans les
lieux de culte est donc prohibée sur le
territoire des mesures prises par le
gouvernement et confirmé vendredi par le
conseil d'état ce dernier dit avoir reçu
vente et une requête d'associations et
membres du clergé catholique demandant
la suspension des restrictions demande
rejetée
il est nécessaire de prévenir que cet
état tant pis vers des considérations
tyrannique
il faut que les ministres cesse aussi et
bien d' étaler sur la place publique
leur incompétence leur méconnaissance de
la spécificité du culte catholique
on a des des comment s'appelle dépôt de
trucs qui d'alcooliques aux antes et
et puis surtout l'histoire pays fait que
nous avons de grandes églises et donc
qu'il n'ya pas de problèmes pour
effectuer les distances demandé une
limite de 30 personnes pour les
enterrements et de 6 pour les mariages
mais une fois exercer à titre individuel
les msc grande cérémonie reste donc
interdite
ce qui n'a pas empêché la semaine
dernière n'ont t et versailles et de se
réunir devant des églises des appels ont
été lancés pour ce week end du 14 et 15
novembre dans plusieurs grandes villes
de france
hier les manifestants catholiques
parisiens étaient munis d'une
autorisation préfectorale
si le ministre de l'intérieur dit
comprendre la liberté de culte
il rappelle que la priorité reste la
lutte contre le coronavirus je ne
souhaite pas envoyer des policiers
verbalisent et des croyants devant une
église mais s'il s'agit d'un acte
répéter je le ferai dès ce week end il
n'y aura plus de week end mansuétude pas
de relâchement côté gouvernement donc et
la perspective d'une fête de noël
particulière cette année dont cette
période folle que nous vivons nous avons
besoin de temps de respiration nous
avons besoin d'une trêve
nous avons besoin de retrouver les nos
proches nos familles si jamais il
fallait au parvis en 2020 devienne ce
qu'étaient les ronds-points en 2018
alors je pense que croyants ou non nous
nous mobiliserons de manière extrêmement
énergique et nombreuses pour faire
valoir de liberté gérald darmanin a
prévu de recevoir ce lundi les
représentants des principaux cultes pour
évoquer les conditions de tenue
prochaine des cérémonies selon le
contexte sanitaire
le ministre de l'intérieur appelle je
cite chacun à respecter la loi de la
république